los meses de creciente descontento
llegaron a su punto álgido este sábado
en sri lanka cuando cientos de
manifestantes irrumpieron en la
residencia oficial del presidente a los
que la policía intentó detener
utilizando gas lacrimógeno pero sirvió
de poco
ya que centenares de personas
atravesaron las puertas y entraron en el
edificio
los manifestantes recurrieron a los
pasillos del edificio presidencial
pidiendo la dimisión del presidente
gotabaya rajapaksa
otros no perdieron el tiempo sintiéndose
como en casa nadie vio a rajapaksa
trasladado el día anterior y actualmente
en paradero desconocido en todo colombo
miles de personas salieron a las calles
a pedir un cambio
para abandonen el país no pueden
gobernar este país como es debido
tenemos hijos estamos en la calle
dejando nuestros trabajos porque creemos
en la causa amamos el país amamos a
nuestros hijos estamos sufriendo
el cambio que no tardó en llegar pocas
horas después de que el primer ministro
de rree blanca aceptara dimitir con la
condición de que todos los partidos
aceptaran formar un gobierno de
coalición el actual gobierno ha sido
señalado por su mala gestión en la peor
crisis económica desde la independencia
del país la inflación ha subido hasta el
70 por ciento provocando escasez de
alimentos a medicinas y combustible
crisis que ha empujado a muchos a
protestar desafiando los toques de queda
y las prohibiciones de manifestarse